hey guys welcome back to grizzly Valley
today I'll be working on a Roman
restaurant and that's also the reason
why it's not as long with an episode as
the past ones basically because I built
this restaurant and a couple of areas
around it as well and basically finish
this general area which I still had
between the Alpine and the Roman part of
the park and that just really felt like
a good way to and the episode at least
in a coherent way and not make the
entire episode too messy like I have
said in previous episodes I'm not sure
if I'll really be able to keep these
videos like very thematic working on a
single thing in a single episode as I do
really like to do because there are
those smaller things all around the park
like some smaller unfinished things that
I still need to get to and I will get to
in some future episodes after this one
but yeah that is basically about all of
the planning that I have the moments for
this restaurant itself it is very
heavily inspired by the Roman villas I
really just want to get that style in
there like I'm really playing with a
couple of different styles of Roman
architecture and at least getting all of
the general ideas of Roman buildings in
here so have the very temple style
buildings for these stations the very
city esque buildings on the other side
of the same area and I wanted to try
some more rural villa like style for
this restaurants to be able to actually
get that style in as well and play
around a bit with that - it's definitely
not as interesting of a style
gameplay-wise since I want to keep it a
lot more clean like I've played a lot
with different objects in different uses
and very intricate details with the
previous styles but the Roman villas are
pretty much no-nonsense pretty simple
white walls with red roofs and the only
real special thing that they have going
for them which makes them quite a bit
more recognisable and is probably also
the most recognizable aspects of this
building is having that little gallery
in front of the building where the roofs
kind of hang over the gallery and we
have some pillars and just a small path
that goes underneath that roof and
that's really the only thing I really
wanted to have here
but aside from that it's actually just a
great box which is meant to look like a
Roman villa from the front and I'll just
be housing a simple restaurant in here
it's not the best placing for
restaurants but it's right about the
only thing which I figured I could fit
into this tight space here without
leaving too much open and also without
making the building too large and not
having a proper border or transition
between the alpine area and the main
streets and the Roman area which I have
over here so that's basically the sort
of idea that went into the building but
it's more or less filler of the area in
a sense that it it is not it isn't
definitely not a weenie so it's not
really meant to really draw attention to
it but just to fill up the area a bit
more and get an atmospheric going in the
area have a restaurants because that's
from a well Park realism aspect still
handy in any case and also have like
some way and I was kind of struggling
with how I was going to layout this area
and Flextronics actually talks about
this in his last video siege video - how
very often you build things and you're
very insecure about what it's going to
be like while you're building it and I
really really felt that way during this
especially but I very often do feel that
way it's also very discouraging quite
often like I lay off playing the game
very often just because I feel like I'm
not actually going somewhere with what
I'm building even even if I am actually
going and a pretty good and steady way
and that's really how I felt in this
area because I had all those paths going
off on a slope there with the future
Rock work and I wasn't really sure how
to fill in this area to actually make it
come together like I felt a wall of
buildings over here would just not fit
with having neat rocks on the other side
like it would be too striking of a
contrast between the very urban looking
facades and the the very just natural
rocks and foliage where I can really
build any buildings or place flat rides
just because it's it doesn't really work
well with the terrain so I was really
hoping that this restaurant could
somehow make this area look a lot better
in the end with the pathways in front of
it
and I'm actually quite happy with how it
turned out but it's definitely not too
spectacular on its own just something
that I really needed to get in here as
as a way to make this entire area just
finished as a whole and something that I
also kind of just needed to get myself
encouraged a bit again because I was
incredibly insecure about how that's
going to look and I know that I very
very often just stop building things
when I get to that point that I'm not
sure where I'm going with something and
I don't really like the look of things
as it's just halfway finished and I
really have to say it sometimes it's
best to push yourself and just say well
that you should just work on something
even if you have no real idea as to what
you really want to do because as soon as
you get to just filling in the area and
adding the last details especially when
it comes to foliage which makes a really
really big difference things can very
often just start looking a lot better
than they were looking when you're
halfway through the building process and
it's the same goes for the park as a
whole really one of the reasons why I
want to focus the future couple of
episodes on some smaller things and not
so much the thematic episodes of
building one thing at a time
preferably wienies is because there are
just those unfinished parts of the park
with just empty cross lands and it
doesn't really come together well and I
really want to start filling in those
areas to get a better idea of what the
park as a whole is going to look like
and flow like layout wise so that's why
I want to focus a bit more on that as
well there's also the reason that
obviously there's still almost one month
to go until the second alpha release but
I have to say I do feel like we're
really about to run out of options
really with the current build there are
definitely still many ideas and many
themes that I see people try and really
some amazing work but like I really feel
we're well reaching the limits in a
sense here know in a sense that we can't
really come up with new themes with the
current pieces it's definitely possible
but you can't use
different textures and it's you start
becoming that you start getting this
effect that every Park eventually ends
up looking very similar at least in this
current build of the Alpha because even
if you go for different themes and make
different buildings and compose things
in a completely different way we are
stuck with the current textures and
there's not much that you can sort of do
outside of the things that have been
done because at this point in time
nearly everybody has bit has built
buildings using nearly all of the pieces
that we even have at the moment or sorta
it's sort of like we're running out of
juice here and I I definitely don't want
to say I'll give up on this porc that's
definitely not the case but I feel like
it isn't really worth it so much - just
keep experimenting as much as I went
into this park with like the first
number of episodes we just tried
different themes and see what we can do
with all the pieces in this game but at
this point I have we've sort of come up
with a lot of users for the pieces
already and I've gotten a lot more
experience with things as well and it
doesn't feel as experimental and as much
anymore and I just want to focus more on
making the park itself come together so
I guess it's best described as a very
short summary has that I don't wanna
focus as much on the individual
buildings anymore but from now on also a
bit more on how the park itself is going
to look and at least connected in such a
way that grizzly Valley can be a
realistic park or at least somewhat
realistic as much as I can get and not
just a collection of interesting
buildings and interesting themes but
with no real connection or any coherence
in the park as a whole
see how that's basically that's um and
yeah for the restaurant itself it's it's
really a simple restaurants at the most
prominent thing really on the building
is that little gallery on the bottom I
did want to have a slightly raised part
just behind this lower gallery just to
have a little bit more depth through the
building then it would have with just
one level and it's also a kind of design
that's very typical and standard almost
I would say for a Roman
like this but yeah that's basically the
entire idea behind the building I wanted
to keep it quite clean
so no unnecessary details really because
at that we just feel like overdoing the
building and it just feels like it's
better being a little bit simplistic
sometimes which I would reckon sometimes
buildings are just left better
simplistic especially when you go into
modern things and it it all comes down
to shape of course but definitely for
buildings like these as well I didn't
want to overly decorate it also with the
mice since it's a villa but still it
can't really be that expensive to build
realism wise so yeah that was the idea
for that I wanted to have a small pillar
over here just because I felt I could
have Rock work over here and this was
really that space where I felt I had
like no other options than to just
decorate it in a sense the space is too
small to add a flat right and there are
the sloped pathways over here it's
nearly impossible to really and a
building here and I also wanted to keep
it quite open so you would be able to
see the arch from the coastal area but
also the other way around just so you
can see the Roman area parts from the
other part within the area just keep it
more like one area and not close off
certain area parts of the area too much
from the other parts so I wouldn't keep
it quite open not have any buildings or
flat rides I but I did want to have
something and not just have rocks or
turn it into a forest and I really would
have loved to turn this into a small
grassy hill but there is no way I can
realistically do so so I figured just a
couple of rockwork hills over here will
have to do because I need to somehow get
some terraforming in and to make it not
seem so much like just a barren a
completely natural sort of rock work
facade I tried to at least with that
pillar in there and make it a bit more
like kind of the rock work that you have
around the forum remaining in a sense as
well and just have that bit of
decoration in there and do the same with
the foliage really instead of just
having some standard foliage and clog it
up with a lot of trees I wanted to also
keep the foliage very open and also very
men made a very blunted in quite a
systematic way so with a couple of small
palm trees just placed in a straight
line and some tsipras's placed in a
straight line which is fairly typical of
Italian landscapes as well and just
dress it up that way and hope that it
would somehow become something that I
would like and after that I really
wanted to go to the foliage over here in
this area which is quite important for a
number of reasons it's pretty good
against the back as a backdrop for the
Italian restaurant so you don't just
have this enormous wall of well white
walls and light roofs over there but
actually have some nice vibrant foliage
behind the building just a little bit
higher than the building itself to
actually make it stand out from its
surroundings in a sense and also to act
as a border between this area these
areas which was a very narrow border so
I had to make it quite a dense little
patch of foliage over there but it's
something that I really needed to get in
there to get rid of the pretty big white
wall of the Italian part and also to
make sure that you wouldn't be able to
see the Italian building from the Alpine
area and vice versa the only building
that you will be able to see from the
Italian area is going to be the castle
on top of the mountain but there isn't
much that I can do about that and it's
almost in a a Disneyland kind of way
really and the very dense foliage around
here was also quite helpful because it
makes the coaster a bit more like it
actually interacts with the environment
it was a pretty still part of the
coaster with just a couple of helixes
some airtime Hills and aside from just
being next to a path it doesn't really
do much and the path doesn't have much
going for it either so I just wanted to
add some dense foliage over there so you
kind of still have that idea with Ebola
coaster that you're really flying
through the field through the trees if
it were especially given how the coaster
is really made up of two parts where one
part is like it only interacts with the
mountain and it really goes in and over
this mountain area and in the second
part it really sweeps throughout the
park so I sort of wanted to at least
keep some interaction with many of
things in the park so you really have
this idea that you're just flying
through the forests and over the park
over the paths over here and keep that
quite close together really to not make
it like just a coaster in the middle of
a forest that doesn't really interact
with anything else but at least keep
some overlapping elements there and just
as a final little touch for this
entrance to the area actually make the
aqueduct a little bit larger so you
actually have the aqueduct effects over
here as well and it's almost like it's
split in two because there is that
pretty dense foliage in between it which
I do kind of like because it doesn't
really seem like a huge wall because of
it and then over here with the plaza
with the triumphal arch there was one
thing I wanted to try as a last idea I
didn't want to have buildings all around
the sides of this because it would just
be quite unmanageable and also feel
unnecessary and expensive for this type
of park not to mention that there's
hardly any space for it so just to make
it seem a little bit more urban and also
get some Coliseum ish vibes from it as
well I figured I might as well put a
round archway or a bunch of arches in a
round sort of set up around that but
that's something I'll also have to
finish and see how it's gonna look at
some later stage anyway thank you guys
for watching this episode and please